un service d'urbanisme reconstitué pour
expliquer la réglementation du paysage
urbain la ville de rambouillet joue la
carte de l'exposition ont tout ce qui
concerne le site patrimonial remarquable
dès que vous touchez l'extérieur d'un
bâtiment va vendre une maison à la
façade par exemple vous devez venir nous
rendre visite quand vous explique ce que
vous pouvez ou pas faire et à ce moment
là on vous accompagne avant toute
l'instruction de dossiers à vendre
la délivrance du permis de construire
des jeux ludiques pour entrer dans un
sujet très technique le s p r site
patrimonial remarquable vise à conserver
le patrimoine existant et l'aspect
culturel de la commune
cette exposition elle vise à aider les
administrés à s'approprier cette
réglementation à leur donner des trucs
pour qu'ils puissent utiliser plus
facilement et à ce que tout le monde
même ceux qui sont pas directement
concernés en comprennent l'intérêt de
l'expo vraiment joue la carte de la
sténographie de la mise en scène du
ludique de l'expérimentation et
l'interactivité de façon à ce que tout
le monde puisse se retrouver et au mois
en repartir avec les idées principales
les équipes on pensait plusieurs niveaux
de lecture pour répondre à tous les âges
et toutes les questions une rue fictive
a été créé en mêlant bâti du xviiie
début 19e traditionnelle et une
architecture de villégiature fin du
19ème jusqu'à l'entre-deux-guerres
à vous de deviner qui des boulangers ou
des antiquaires sont les bons élèves